digamos que queremos encontrar x de la
siguiente ecuación racional x + 1 entre
9 x es igual a dos tercios pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo antes de
que lo resolvamos juntos muy bien vamos
a resolverlo juntos hay varias formas de
resolver esto la forma que a mí me gusta
es quitar primero esta equis del
denominador y la forma más sencilla que
conozco de hacer esto es multiplicar
ambos lados de esta ecuación por 9 menos
x cuando hacemos esto es importante
indicar el calificador donde se señala
que x no puede ser igual al valor que
hace que el denominador sea igual a 0 si
yo hago esta manipulación algebraica y
resulta que x es igual a 9 no sería una
solución válida porque si sustituimos 9
en la ecuación original estaríamos
dividiendo entre 0 lo que es una
indeterminación por lo que escribimos
que x no puede ser igual a 9 ahora
podemos continuar con confianza haciendo
las manipulaciones algebraicas
necesarias
del lado izquierdo estamos multiplicando
y dividiendo entre 9 menos x por lo que
se cancelan y nos queda x 1 y del lado
derecho si multiplicamos dos tercios por
nueve menos x
tenemos que dos tercios por nueve es
igual a seis y que dos tercios por menos
x es igual a menos dos tercios de x y
recordemos que x no debe ser igual a 9
ahora ponemos las x del mismo lado vamos
a poner las del lado izquierdo sumamos
dos tercios de x en ambos lados dos
tercios de x dos tercios de x
y nos queda del lado izquierdo tenemos
una equis o lo que es lo mismo tres
tercios de x más dos tercios de x es
igual a cinco tercios de x más uno y
esto es igual a seis estos términos se
cancelan luego restamos uno en ambos
lados y nos queda 5 tercios de x es
igual a 5 y por último pero no menos
importante multiplicamos ambos lados de
esta ecuación por el recíproco de 5
tercios que es tres quintos y hacemos
esto para que quede la x solita del lado
izquierdo por tres quintos y nos queda
trescientos por cinco tercios es igual a
uno aquí queda x que es igual a cinco
por tres quintos que es igual a tres
tenemos confianza en que x es igual a
tres pero tenemos que asegurarnos de que
esto es consistente con la ecuación
original así aquí sustituimos x con 3 no
queda 0 en el denominador ya que x no es
igual a 9 por lo que estamos seguros de
que esta es la solución
si hubiéramos hecho toda esta
manipulación algebraica y resultará que
x era igual a 9 no hubiera sido una
solución válida porque habría hecho que
la ecuación original fuera indeterminada